drink you know I'm a little I would love
I don't need a whole life story just yes
or no yes Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner
really do keep up with the Kardashians
I'm so excited about it the lovebirds
show off another tribute to the famous
family on Tick Tock after impersonating
them plenty of times in the past I don't
know what's going on this time they're
recreating a classic moment between
Scott Disick and Kris Jenner drink you
know I'm a little I would love I don't
need a whole life story just yes or no
the Joe Bro channels the OG momager it's
like a dream experience dream role and
The Game of Thrones star takes on the
role of Lord dise drink you know I'm a
little I would love I don't need a whole
life story just yes or no yes I was
going to give you a whole thing about
how I was so nauseous that's a lot of
course the couple has given fans a lot
of Peaks at married life taking to the
app with shopping trips
here in the bag good
night and breaking down their favorite
Taylor Swift albums reputation was
inspired by a partly inspired by Santana
did you know that
really yeah
that's really cool yeah but not as cool
as their impressions of Kylie and
Courtney is that I'm gonna get wasted I
just finished a whole cup of 42 and I'm
about to go for my second one Courtney
what the are you on I don't know
what's going on so I'm just appreciating
my bread
rewind to 2020 the Jonas Brothers
recreated this iconic moment
I'll hurt you don't do that oh my god
well three years later Joe's moved on
from his Kim impression to Mom Chris
drink
you know Emily I would love I don't need
a whole life story just yes or no but
when these two aren't playing
Kardashians for fun their full-time
roles are Mom and Dad how are you
finding being a family of four it's
amazing um you know genuinely um being a
dad rules yep Joe and Sophie are proud
parents of two kids welcoming
two-year-old Willa in 2020 followed by
another daughter last year to my little
ones at home Daddy loves you to the moon
and back that's Joe a few months ago
shouting out his loves at the Jonas
Brothers Walk of Fame ceremony Sophie
what up homie
drink you know I'm a little I would love
I don't need a whole life story just yes
or no
[Music]